I was nine when I wanted to die.
13 when I found a solution.
You're watching
the for you page of a
teen's TikTok account.
Love will not heal me.
CNN created this TikTok profile
with the help of a 14 year old
and their parents before
taking control of it.
Over six days,
we use this account
to see what kinds of content
the app would serve to a young person
Seems to be sort of giving you a guide
for how to develop an eating disorder,
how to restrict or eating.
What surprised me most
the content that I was served
while in restricted mode.
But that comes later. First.
All right, let's do it.
This is the first time that I'm going
to be opening this TikTok
and looking at the for you page
for the first two days.
I scrolled the test accounts for you page
for 30 minutes.
About a third of the amount of time
a typical U.S.
teen spends on the app each day,
according to a TechCrunch report.
And they watched each video.
I came across in full just once.
At first we saw a lot of this.
All the wonderful things
that the brain can do.
It can go like a cow.
We can go, move, move. And this
oh, but about
17 minutes into our first day,
we were served with this video.
Now we've come to a live video.
All we're really seeing
is the scrolls bottom in the frame.
It looks like
that's the point of this video.
And about 18 minutes into day two,
we came across this video.
So now we've got one that has it
hashtag mental health on it.
You got a kill you.
If you want to show me.
We have a sort of like veiled reference
to suicide in here, sort of mature
themes happening here.
I think a lot of
parents are sitting there going.
Hold on a sec.
I thought Tik Tok was about dance crazes.
On day three,
we started searching for content
using search terms
from both the lawsuit
filed by the Indiana Attorney General's
Office and research
from the online safety
advocacy group Center for Countering
Digital Hate.
The Indiana AG alleges
that teenagers can type
partial search terms
and the Apple autocomplete
with suggestions
that could surface inappropriate content.
TikTok has said
it doesn't comment on pending litigation,
but that user safety is a top priority.
First, we replicated their search
for alcohol
and drug
related content and didn't immediately
find anything that seemed harmful.
I'm not saying anything
that has to do with alcohol
on the first page of search results.
Then we replicated their searches
for sexual content Type
Chi, and our second result is Tik Tok.
We're getting some pretty sort
of adult mature content
that we're seeing here.
You hope that
we're getting
all of these other suggestions.
Kin Tik Tok, Daddy's
girl, kin tik tok, ropa
kin tik tok scenario rough.
And maybe you're typing chi
because you're searching something
completely unrelated to this,
but it was a second search result.
And so you could see how somebody
might come across this kind of content
sort of accidentally.
When we search terms mentioned
in the research by the Center
for Countering Digital Hate.
We found dozens of videos
related to eating disorders
and self-harm Tik Tok has pushed back
against the group's research,
saying it wasn't representative
of a real person's
experience on the platform.
Still, many of the hashtags
mentioned in the research
remained active
and quickly led us to concerning
content immediately.
The first result looks like
it's about eating disorder, recovery.
In this video,
we have someone talking
about drawing food
so they don't actually have to eat food
when it's talking about eating
disorders, safe foods.
A lot of these videos,
you have thousands of views,
hundreds of comments, thousands of saves
and a lot of these videos
do look like
they're sort of targeted towards talking
about recovery.
But it's not always exactly clear.
I think it's really important that people
speak their truth
and have their voices
to talk about their recovery.
But the question is, should TikTok
knowingly be sending that again
and again
to 13 year old girls
who perhaps don't yet
have the vocabulary
or the emotional intelligence
to be able to cope
with these sorts of concepts?
These clips may seem shocking,
but in some cases
we chose not to show the most
disturbing and explicit content
when we clicked through
to this person's account.
You see in the description
that says Some of my videos
have my self-harm scars.
So trigger warning.
On day five,
we turned on Restricted Mode,
a feature that TikTok says limits videos
that may be inappropriate
for some people.
Then we recreated the same searches.
We done on day three
to see if it would change our results.
This is almost pornographic.
We found that restricted mode.
It didn't seem to restrict
much of anything.
We actually saw the same video
when we were not on restricted mode.
I think we may have seen this one, too.
And this one,
this actually
seems like almost all of the same videos
that we saw previously.
Oh my God.
People suppression gets so bad
they can't brush their teeth.
People's depression
get so bad, they kill themselves. Janet.
This didn't pop up before.
You are more than your weight.
If you or someone you know
has questions
about body image, food
or exercise is important to know
that help is out there.
So it's kind of interesting that TikTok
seems to have recognized that.
I was looking at a lot of eating
disorder weight loss related content.
And yet while we're on restricted mode,
it's not sort of change
the fact that I can see
all of this stuff.
TikTok says it sometimes
directs users to resources for issues
such as eating disorders
and self-harm
based on the search terms
they use
in response to questions from CNN.
The company updated to additional
eating disorder hashtags.
So they now redirect to support
resources.
All right.
We're speeding on days five and six.
We scroll the for you page for 30 minutes
while on restricted mode.
And we saw a slight uptick in mental
health related videos
Have another depression
related video again
in the comments you have.
I can relate to this,
and I'm only in middle school.
I can relate to this
and I'm in high school.
Okay.
We've got hashtags suicide hashtag.
Don't Kill Yourself.
Explaining my depression to my mother.
A conversation
CNN flagged more than a dozen videos
we came across during our experiment
to Tik Talk.
It removed three of them
for violating its
community guidelines, including this one,
which you saw at the top of this video.
Her my heartbeat
pounding my ears like a warning drum,
then face I'd almost convinced myself
I've done it.
We've known for a long time
for actually content about self-harm
and suicide can have an instigator effect
on young people
and the normalization of self-harm
is incredibly dangerous.
Our test account
didn't behave exactly
like a real teen would,
and much of the content
we saw also fell into a gray area
that may or may not
be concerning to parents,
but it did show what
a teen could encounter on the app.
In a statement, spokesperson
Ben Rate said TikTok is committed
to building age
appropriate experiences
for teens and offers family pairing.
TikTok also removed to search suggestions
that led to sexual content.
Tik Tok has also added
various youth safety features
including a screen time limit, keyword
filters and options
for diversifying users feeds.
Still, online
safety experts are urging
TikTok to do more.
And in the meantime,
they say
parents should be aware
of what their kids see on the app.
They need to be having conversations
with their kids, asking them,
what are you seeing?
And then helping them to contextualize
that by having that conversation,
we can actually help
kids and parents understand better
this new social media age that
for better or worse, live in.